[Music]
nice grip smile your arms good
since season one Abby who's a trainer at
the gym she's been lying that she
trained Shania Twain which came about
just because trained and Twain sounds
school so it was kind of just like a
stream of consciousness I'm training
Shania Twain and as fate would have it
today we have Shania Twain as a guest
man I feel like smoothie she was so
funny
she was so down to play with herself as
an icon she like rips this song as a
spark you've gotta write it down now
well there's a spa you gotta ride it oh
when you're in love don't hide it oh we
were singing that for like the crew was
singing that it's such an honor she was
so fun and sweet and funny honestly I
want to go home and watch friends Oh
such a Chandler I'm so - Rachel little
Gunther also know I'm a little bit Feeny
mmm
in terms of Abby and Tracy I Namek we
never saw it coming it's something that
kind of just happened
say you Trey just say it once missing
he's a fitness guy and she's like a
quirky artist girl and he doesn't really
get her but Trey really cares about
happy and has always really liked her at
some point we realized and just shooting
a scene trained IVF chemistry
something's going on and then Alana was
like yes this is happening and so it
kind of snowballed from there but people
who watch the show
seemed to be really into it and like
shipped Abby and Trey and so it was
really almost a surprise to all of us we
really liked the idea that the broad
city world keeps living even when we're
not watching it you know stuff happened
between Abby and Trey and like fell
apart
a bee-like just didn't handle it right
at the end Trey and the gym didn't have
any closure we wanted to give Trey a
goodbye you know a farewell let me train
her with you okay I could be your goose
do not bring up Top Gun right now it
felt like a different way of
storytelling it was like backtracking of
like dealing with the end of a hookup
just felt like a really fun way of
finishing off their story you call it
can you call nine-one-one yeah his dick
is definitely broken
[Music]